[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la deûle a grandi interview avec
cette semaine thierry drion bonjour vous
êtes hajaoui tué presque de vous êtes
déjà venu dans cette émission vous êtes
présidente de la chambre de commerce
franco britannique absolue vous étiez
venu à un moment où les négociations
pour le break site et est au plus bas au
niveau du moral des négociateurs parce
qu'il n'y arrivait pas ils ont négocié
pendant cinq ans quand même le vote a eu
lieu en 2016
on a fêté le 5 enfin on a fait t on à
commémorer le 20e le cinquième
anniversaire de ce vote le 25 le 23 et
il c'est devenu maintenant une réalité
donc depuis le 31 décembre de l'année
dernière à minuit alors tiré des rayons
vous avez depardon fonction assister à
toutes ces négociations
minute par minute vous êtes sans doute
un des témoins clé est pas partisans
puisque vous êtes des deux côtés de la
barrière
si j'ose dire vous êtes un des mieux
placés pour répondre à trois séries de
questions en gros un d'abord on a envie
de connaître l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui la maintenant que le bric
cité d'effectifs et puis quelles sont
les conséquences de tout ça qui perd qui
gagne et puis l'évolution probable
qu'ils aient pas évidente parce que la
visibilité est pas est pas
extraordinaire aujourd'hui l'actualité
nous a apporté à actuellement un certain
nombre de faits sur lesquels on va
revenir mais la visibilité n'est pas
bonne
key drion la grande bretagne a donc eu
cinq ans pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame ça contre
négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
alors d'abord remercier votre invitation
et la dernière fois où vous m'avez
invité vous m'aviez posé la question on
était au plus bas dans le nez dans la
discussion je vous avais dit que j'étais
extrêmement optimiste parce que le
réalisme et le pragmatisme est allé
l'emporter mais bon finalement les
choses m'ont donné raison à l'optimisme
chez vous je pensais que vous alliez
penser que le président n'avait pas se
faire alors ne nous conviendrait en
arrière non non non non j'ai jamais dis
que ça revient leur manière j'ai
toujours des choses allaient se faire
parce qu'il y avait un choix
démocratique et que les choses devaient
se mettre en place et qu'un cadre
allaient être créés alors oui
effectivement depuis
1er janvier officiellement le royaume
uni a quitté l'union européenne
est-ce qu'elle était totalement prête la
réponse est non et si pour tck art de
briques site
alors après de si tu sais que simplement
il y avait un certain nombre de contours
qui restent à définir
je vous rappelle juste une chose il faut
que jusqu'au remettre les choses en
perspective
l'accord est intervenu le 24 décembre 1
dans un espèce de psychodrame 1er
janvier et on a donné un contrat cadre
mais au-delà de ce contrat cadre il faut
encore revenir mais c'est 682 accords
bilatéraux et multinationaux qui ont été
signés entre le royaume uni et la des
pays de l'union européenne donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut détricoter il faut
prendre le temps de détricoter michel
barnier à juste titre qui a fait un
travail exceptionnel avec ses équipes a
dit ça prendra des mois voire des années
je pense que ça prendra plusieurs années
deux trois quatre ans pour que tout soit
totalement détricoter mais attendez on a
quand même aujourd'hui des actualités
des faits qu'il faut régler de façon
urgente à partir depuis le 31 décembre
on a remis en place des douanes des deux
côtés de du channel on en a on a remis
un contrôle des flux commerciaux assez
précis on est en train de vérifier si
les résidents européens en grande
bretagne ont bien fait leur demande de
résidanat permanent on est en train de
déménager un certain nombre
d'entreprises une banque comme jpmorgan
s'est installé cette semaine à paris pas
en totalité mais enfin ça nous a valu
quand même une visite du président de la
république vous avez bien est en
campagne électorale mais enfin bon tout
ça tout ça crée des problèmes
ou est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui alors
plusieurs éléments d'abord vous me posez
la question est ce que nos amis
britanniques étaient tellement près la
réponse est non la deuxième chose c'est
que vous avez parlé du des douanes
1 on avait effectué éléments plus
visible
c'est l'élément plus visibles parce que
c'est les chances de biens et de
services
on avait dit que ça allait être juste a
à k o et sa lettre la fin du monde ça
n'a pas été le cas il a fallu le
désajustement je note simplement que
côté des douanes françaises avec tout
bleu le principe de la douane numérique
et du principe digitalisées les choses
sont extrêmement fluide la douane
intelligente et voilà et côté de nos
amis britanniques
cette optique ou trop petit mais sa
taille ne marche pas je joue à l'ailé
ces mots justes à mener de l'autre côté
côté britannique
les choses ne sont pas préparés et les
deux systèmes se parlent pas donc à un
moment donné et principe de réalité
la deuxième chose c'est que il ya un
certain nombre de mesures douanières qui
s'applique côté de l'union européenne
mais nos amis britanniques ont dit bah
écoute et comme on n'est pas totalement
prêt on va se donner un peu plus de
temps voilà donc il ya un décalage à ce
niveau là et aujourd'hui force est de
constater que cela crée un certain
nombre de perturbations dans l'ensemble
des transactions économiques entre les
deux pays je vous rappelle c'était avant
la pandémie
c'était un peu plus de 100 milliards 103
milliards s'est on s'interpelle d'être
et les deux maîtresses interpénétrés et
et quand vous regardez l'ensemble des
transactions dans le détail regardez le
monde ce qui se fait dans le domaine de
l'agroalimentaire et on parlera du
problème et l'irlande du nord qui est un
vrai sujet qui est un trou dans la
raquette
voilà et notamment pour tout ce qui est
agroalimentaire et tout ce qui est on va
dire exportations de produits animaliers
mais aujourd'hui les choses sont en
train de se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide la réponse est non
mais personne ne pouvait penser que les
choses allaient se passer du jour au
lendemain et de manière extrêmement
sensible est ce que vous le confirmer il
ya effectivement pas eu de catastrophe
n'a pas eu de rupture
d'approvisionnement
les magasins n'ont pas manqué de
produits frais par exemple alors la
réponse est non sauf que sauf que il ne
vous aura pas échappé si par exemple
vous à acheter des produits dans une
grande marque britannique en france sur
des produits alimentaires ils les rayons
étaient pour le moins vides
donc il a fallu un temps d'adaptation
côté le journal régional des produits
frais qui sont qui sont achetés par les
anglais aux italiens aux
miolles où les choses se sont faites
sauf que les délais ont été rallongés et
les mesures administratives ont été
sensiblement rallongée de deux à trois
jours donc ça a paru des produits frais
donc ça a un impact sur un certain type
de produits aujourd'hui les choses sont
rentrées dans l'ordre
mais il a fallu ajuster l'ensemble des
mesures et dans les chaînes de
fabrication automobile par exemple où
les chaînes de valeur sont assez
compliquées il ya beaucoup de ya
beaucoup de pièces détachées sur des
usines de montage qui a beaucoup en
grande-bretagne hollande dans la santé
aussi on a eu des problèmes
alors ils ont eu des profs vous avez
tout à fait raison de noter finalement
ce phénomène de chaînes de valeur parce
que le vrai sujet c'est quelle est le
niveau d'exposition au niveau de
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur et sur
quels types de produits
le royaume uni fait beaucoup
d'assemblage vous l'avez rappelé
notamment dans le secteur de
l'automobile
je vais prendre une voiture qui n'est
plus britannique y est maintenant
allemand qui est la mini la fameuse mini
une mini vendus sur le territoire
britannique c'est 28 % de la valeur de
la voiture qui sont des pièces qui sont
assemblés donc uniquement 28% et
fabriqué je vous dire sur le territoire
britannique
donc aujourd'hui le sujet de la chaîne
de valeur l impact tout le monde
elle impacte l'ensemble du secteur de
l'automobile vous aura pas échappé que
cette pandémie a généré à sa tante de
problématiques sur de l'acier et sur un
certain nombre de pièces détachées qui
sont essentiels donc c'est pas
uniquement
on va dire l'économie britannique c'est
l'économie mondiale dans le secteur
l'automobile qui aujourd'hui est
impactée je veux vous embête un peu main
mais mais vous semblez reprendre un
certain nombre d'arguments que semble
donner boris johnson quand les choses
vont mal c'est de la fausse de l'europe
quand les choses vont mieux et mai
qu'elles vont mal c'est tout cas c'est
aussi de la faute du coc vide quoi il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui est fautif alors
vous savez je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
derrière votre question est ce que rien
ne remet si votre jeu vous dire je crois
que nos amis britanniques ont fait un
choix en 2016 qui est un choix et je les
dis et redis qui je pense va impacter
l'économie profondément sur les prix
chen années peut-être une même une
décennie et va impacter des générations
donc je vais dire quelque part je force
est de constater que nous respectons ce
choix démocratique
je le regrette profondément d'un point
de vue économique
est-ce que ça va avoir un impact sur
l'ensemble des transactions à venir
la réponse est oui alors il ya deux
choses il ya d'un côté un court terme et
l'impact à court terme il est réel il
est important à l'heure entre la
pandémie et la partie briques site et
deux sont liés et le deuxième sujet
c'est la capacité de rebond de
l'économie britannique dans les années à
venir
mais j'ai toujours dit de manière
extrêmement claire que lance tu regardes
factuellement les chiffres importation
exportation
aujourd'hui l'économie britannique est
affecté de manière extrêmement lisible
et affecté lorsque vous écoutez
l'ensemble des dirigeants économiques
qui font des transactions avec le
royaume uni
ils ont pour certains fait des choix de
relocalisation ailleurs alors il ya un
secteur donc et qui visiblement affecté
c'est le secteur financier c'est le
point fort de la city à londres sa
réputation sa puissance et sa richesse
c'étaient les transactions financières
et et la banque l'assurance et tout ce
qui va avec
on a l'impression là et on l'a vu à
paris qu'un certain nombre de banques
ont commencé leur déménagement est ce
une relocalisation
est-ce que c'est durable est ce que
c'est sérieux est ce que c'est important
est et d'où ça vient ça vient de cette
histoire de passeport financier qu'il
faudrait dont il faudrait nous expliquer
le fonctionnement mais mais mais mais
c'est quand même assez spectaculaire
pour les anglais là on vient d'apporter
combien 800 traders de jp morgan
accueilli par le président de la
république évidemment qui déroule le
tapis rouge
et il a raison c'est son job bien sûr
que c'est sans club alors on va juste
remettre les choses en perspective juste
pour expliquer pour poser huit heures
parce que votre question est très
importante
d'abord quel est le poids de
des services financiers dans l'économie
britannique
il est très très lourd puisque ces 6 9%
du pib' la versus un peu plus de 5%
france point numéro point numéro 2 ce
que vous évoquez jp morgan et cetera ça
date pas d'hier
ça a démarré et les entreprises se sont
préparées il ya des mois des trimestres
et c'est juste vous donner un chiffre
ce sont 440 est une entreprise dans le
secteur financier ou services financiers
tu ce sont soit relocalisée soit qui ont
pris pied sur le continent avec 3
on va dire trois emplacements
privilégiés amsterdam paris et après
l'effort francfort voilà donc papa pas
rendre de manière extrêmement précise
donc l'impact c'est quoi c'est que
l'impact 1 c'est que la bourse
le london stock exchange qui était la
plateforme financer leur sierre était le
coeur a perdu sa position de leadership
au profit d' amsterdam et paris en
numéro 2 je vais juste vous donner un
chiffre
le premier jour de la réouverture des
bourses européennes les transactions qui
ont été effectués entre eux la bourse de
londres et les bourses européennes ont
été en termes de transactions
l'équivalent d'un la journée de quatre
fois l'ensemble de la capitalisation du
cac 40
c'est juste absolument colossal et
heureusement ça a été anticipé alors on
va revenir sur ce point là parce que ce
que vous dites est très très important
par rapport à fonctionnement européen
puis par rapport aux conséquences du
bric site
mais on va s'arrêter quelques secondes
mais on va revenir et notamment sur
cette question du passeport parce que
derrière ça il ya quand même une vraie
raison qui est au coeur finalement de la
relation entre la grande bretagne et
l'europe
le vrai sujet c'est c'est ce sujet du
passeport financiers j'ai le jeu on va
on va en parler dans dans un quart de
seconde
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec thierry drion le
président de la chambre de commerce
franco britannique pour nous expliquer
un peu ce qui se passe sur le sur le
bric site parce qu'on est actuellement
et on le disait dans la première partie
en train de compter les camions de
déménagement on déménage d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises de londres vers le
continent et notamment des banques
ce qu'il faudrait que vous nous
expliquer très précisément parce que ça
c'est votre boulot c'est votre métier
pourquoi les banques étaient tous talons
pourquoi ça marchait à londres parce que
c'était un espace un peu paradisiaque
pour les financiers absolument
alors c'était les réguler alors la
fiscalité lights et tout ça elle
n'allait pas là-bas par hasard elle
n'allait pas là-bas pour le climat sauf
si vous aimez beaucoup d'humilité mais
voilà un as ou si vous êtes breton mort
mais le sujet a été effectivement que la
bourse de londres était devenue un pôle
à la fois de compétences de savoir faire
des expertises et en même temps de
conditions dérégulé bon il ya deux
sujets le premier sujet c'est le
passeport financier et ce passeport
financiers depuis le 1er janvier il vous
aura pas échappé qu'il n'existe plus la
saur financer ça permet quoi ça permet
tout simplement de pouvoir effectuer des
transactions dans un cadre réglementaire
dans un cadre de gouvernance et dans un
cadre de suivi financier qui soit
conforme aux règles européennes
appartement vous quitter l'europe
vous ne bénéficiez plus de cette
protection ou en tout cas de ce cadre
réglementaire donc ça veut dire que
defacto vous sortez vous pouvez pas être
est dedans et dehors renoncé à vouloir
financer n'existe plus ça voulait dire
aussi que des banques américaines comme
jpmorgan s'installer à londres pour
pouvoir aux conditions britanniques
travaillaient sur le marché européen
mais b pour les lèvres
c'est à dire que depuis londres londres
était pour les entreprises américaines
et j'en sais quelque chose pour avoir
dirigé un certain nombre de ces
entreprises étaient quelque part le hub
le point d'accès pour l'ensemble de
l'europe pour rayonner sur l'europe un
peu 5 à pourvoir 1 c'était en tout cas
une zone de compétences et de talents a
pâti au mot le passeport financier
n'existe plus eh bien il a fallu
anticiper ça faisait partie des choses
qui étaient extraits
en clair le deuxième qui se réveille de
départ c'est alors c'était tout
simplement un que dès le départ et
depuis le début ça faisait partie des
conditions clairement énoncée par michel
barnier et l'ensemble des chefs d'état
pour dire on ne peut pas être dedans et
dehors le deuxième sujet il ya le
passeport financier et il ya ce qu'on
appelle les chambres de compensation ou
alors pour entrer sont dans les détails
c'est globalement lorsque voulu faire
des transactions économiques vous avez
des compensations financières entre une
monnaie est une autre songer simplement
que à londres vous avez par an la
compensation financière représente 750
milliards d'euros pour des raisons
évidentes de fluidité des systèmes
financiers l'europe a dit on vous donne
quelques mois complémentaires et donc
ils ont jusque à la rentrée mais à la
rentrée
une décision devra être prise donc
aujourd'hui peuvent le faire
potentiellement à la rentrée ils ne
pourront plus faire dépendant des
discussions avec l'union belge l'origine
jeunes à refuser tout compromis toute
discussion là dessus il a donc laissé
tomber finalement l'un finances de la
ville dont il était maire
pour des raisons quelles sont ces
raisons politiques parce que
l'angleterre va pas perdre gros là je ne
sais pas si là je ne sais pas s'il a
laissé tomber savine laisser tomber les
britanniques et il m'appartient pas de
juger sur ce sujet ça faisait partie de
toute façon par du moment où une houle
ou le royaume uni avait décidé de
quitter l'union européenne il ne pouvait
plus continuer de bénéficier de ce
passeport financier est quelque part de
ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable je
vais juste vous parliez de d'avoir
laissé tomber je dirais plutôt que boris
johnson de mon point de vue a laissé
tomber une autre catégorie que sont les
pêcheurs britannique parce que les
pêcheurs britannique faisait état d'une
demande de récupérer 80% de la pêche
dans les eaux britanniques bon net net
au bout de cinq ans ils vont récupérer
25 % et quand vous regarder dans le
détail c'est un peu surprenant
donc oui là je suis d'accord avec vous
je pense que les pêcheurs britanniques
ont été
l'essai en rase campagne avec ce
problème très particulier des pêcheurs
des pêcheurs britanniques qui sont
confrontés aux pêcheurs français dans
les régions de jersey et guernesey
mais le vrai sujet de la pêche je
voulais honnêtement le sujet de la pêche
c'est un sujet c'est l'actualité
polémique mais économiquement c'est rien
c'est 620 millions d'euros
oui 620 millions d'euros c'est à la fois
beaucoup d'argent mais c'est rien après
une vue économique mais ça c'est la
première chose c'est moins de 1%
et la deuxième chose c'est que tout est
imbriqué c'est à dire que vous avez
certes des eaux très poissonneuses mais
le sujet n'est pas pêché le sujet c'est
de transformer ce poisson d'accord pour
des biens de consommation une vente sur
un marché wii et le marché de ces
marchés europe et la transformation se
fait ou aujourd'hui ouais le les
britanniques n'ont aucune capacité de
faire la transformation 100% de la
transformation se fait sur le territoire
européen
donc on est sur quelque part a marché de
dupes oui en ce qui concerne
l'attractivité que peuvent avoir les
pays européens ils sont en concurrence
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir attirer des
entreprises et notamment les banques
vous parliez de francfort c'est vrai il
ya la banque centrale vous parliez
d'amsterdam c'est vrai que isolé est ce
que la france a des facteurs
d'attractivité important alors je suis
ravi vous posez la question posée en mai
sujet favori les quand même le champion
du monde de la fiscalité alors et alors
je vais vous dire vous vous posez cette
question et je vais m'autoriser attentes
ont dit on se plante on fait des erreurs
et des moments où on peut avoir raison
en 2004 j'ai écrit une tribune qui a été
reprise à la une des échos et qui était
de dire pourquoi je suis franco petit
beast frac optimiste alors il m'a fallu
17 ans pour avoir raison un bon ou en
tout cas pour pas trop faire d'erreur
non je suis extrêmement optimiste en
vient pas chez nous pour payer des
impôts
je suis extrêmement optimiste d'abord je
suis optimiste sur la reprise de
l'économie mondiale parce que tous les
indicateurs et non pas en parler sont au
vert je suis optimiste parce que
finalement l'attractivité
je me félicite laillé
le sommet tous français le quatrième je
vois qu'au dernier baromètre iwai la
france ressort certes de pas grand chose
mais toujours numéro un et ça fait trois
ans que ça dure donc finalement quand je
regarde ça c'est l'étalon la capacité à
accompagner les entreprises la capacité
à développer le secteur de la
technologie et le sujet c'est comment
est-ce qu'on skate toutes ces tares top
et c'est donc la quantité d'éléments qui
sont favorables
voilà et quand vous regardez les autres
pays européens ouais ouais est ce que
l'allemagne est aussi attractif qu'avant
la réponse est non royaume uni on en a
parlé
l'italie et l'espagne donc je veux pas
dire faute de combattants mais il
n'empêche que l'attractivité de la
france et on peut s'en féliciter de
temps en temps se dire qu'elle n'a pas
été aussi importante depuis 20 ans bon
bah sachant sans fil et c'est vrai que
quand les patrons de banques interrogent
leur personnel et qu'il en dise où est
ce que vous préférez à l'hérésie d
habiter francfort et pas très glamour et
qu' ils choisissent pas rien alors si
notre l'attractivité de notre armée
c'est la rêverie vers les gens c'est sur
l'éducation les si les universités c'est
le système social 1 mais est-ce que je
peux m'autoriser un instant le
commentaire d'un copain américain qui
dirige un grand groupe de private equity
je l'avais au téléphone il ya quelques
jours et sa phrase a été de me dire il y
avait garé driving france est juste mais
zing dans son langage et ai dit vous
avez pour une fois un mec qui conduit
les choses qui drague et qui a un impact
international nous plaît pas que db à
l'intérieur mais enfin bon c'est une
autre histoire ça c'est une autre
histoire
je vous parle de rayonnement alors ça
c'est les facteurs d'évolution et avec
les points d'actualité convient qu'on
vient de soulever sur le plus long terme
maintenant comment vous voyez cette
évolution et comment notamment
voyez-vous la façon dont on va régler
les problèmes alors au niveau des
accords commerciaux vous
vous précisiez tout à l'heure tu y en a
à peu près 600 règles et ceux qui ont
été déjà signé on s'aperçoit qu'on
reprend le copier coller de ce qui a été
fait avant un peu une certaine façon
alors là vous parler d'accords
commerciaux avec d'autres avec d'autres
pays oui bof au sérieux faut être
sérieux à ce jour les accords de libre
échange c'est le liechtenstein c'est le
luxembourg et c'est la norvège
donc c'est donc c'est peanuts ouais
ouais bon mais il va falloir signer tout
ça est celui qui est en cours c'est avec
l'australie mais l'australie juste
l'australie ces 24 milliards de
transactions économiques
la france salue 200 milliards le caillou
dans la chaussure c'est l'irlande
absolument qui nous empêche de marcher
les uns comme les autres celui qu'est ce
qui se passe ces jeux je crois que une
négociation il ya un temps pour la
négociation et à temps pour la
discussion
il ya un temps pour la décision et après
il ya un temps pour l'exécution et là on
est dans l'exécution et et ce sujet là
est un sujet sur lequel il ne pourrait y
avoir de retour en arrière et c'est la
raison pour laquelle un certain nombre
d'acteurs au niveau européen à 100
d'actes de goût de d'acteur dans le
domaine public l'élan bonne s'est
prononcée ne peut pas revenir à lörrach
sight quoi nos meilleures de ma part
voilà donc on ne reviendra pas en
arrière les conditions sont fixées on
peut pas prendre ce qui nous intéresse
et mettre de côté ce qui intéresse pas
je ne doute pas qu'à un moment ou un
autre
alors ça fait partie des postures ben il
vous aura pas échappé pendant ses quatre
ans de discussions il ya eu des hauts
des bas et c est que comme par hasard le
24 décembre parce qu'il ya eu un peu
n'est des coups de force et choses se
sont décantées
elles vont se décanter mais on est dans
une phase qui est une phase compliquée
et vous avez tout à fait raison
jean-marc de le dire
le sujet le plus criant est le plus
grave aujourd'hui c'est comment faire en
sorte que ce ce point d'entrée ou en
tout cas ce trou dans la raquette avec
42 nord soit résolu parce que ça c'est
un sujet qui est un sujet sur lequel il
ne peut y avoir embarqué aucune des deux
parties dans une direction qui est
opposée à celle qu'il voudrait
absolument ça va être complètement ça va
être compliqué avec compliqué est-ce que
l'idée qui a circulé pendant très
longtemps que les anglais finalement
l'élite anglaise se disait qu'en
transformant l'angleterre en en
je parlais de singapour tout à l'heure
en singapour de l'europe
c'est une idée qui pourrait les sauver
ou pas ou là où l'air leur préserver un
avenir meilleur est ce que c'est
possible en plus alors un la situation
actuelle nous prouve que c'est
totalement impossible avec des histoires
de fiscalité maladie les rats avec
fiscalité light je n'y crois pas je n'y
crois pas pour plein de raisons pour y
revenir mais si on prend l'exemple une
passeport financiers et des flux
financiers qui ont été quatre fois
supérieur à ce qu'on avait anticipé
donc je n'y vois pas 2 vous parlez de
l'élite
justement cette élite c'est elle qui a
fait penser qu' il n'y aurait jamais de
séparation entre l'union européenne
voilà donc il faut faire attention
3 n'oublions pas j'ai lire toute la
partie des midlands
c'est à dire la partie de birmingham
manchester et c'est qu'ils sont des gens
à qui on a expliqué notamment dans les
années les plus dures de sa chère que la
raison pour laquelle on leur demandait
des efforts considérables et une
transformation de leur économie avec un
niveau de chômage qui étaient les plus
élevés depuis 50 ans main margaret
thatcher leur a expliqué tout ça c'est
de la faute de l'europe
donc ces gens là ont dans leur code
génétique étaient abreuvés de ce
discours nous tiendrions je voudrais pas
qu'on s'arrête
les missions sont sans parler d'une
d'une activité qui vous est personnelle
sur laquelle vous êtes discret mais mais
mais qui est importante dans la mesure
où vous
vous occupez vous avez créé une
fondation des deux côtés du channel
d'ailleurs un pour venir en aide et pour
essayer de favoriser la recherche en mal
sur les maladies du coeur notamment pour
les femmes
vous êtes vous fait des appels aux dons
de des deux côtés du côté britannique
comme du côté français alors c'est une
c'est un fonds de dotation
merci d'en parler et je pense que
finalement en tant que dirigeant
d'entreprise et qui plus est dans le
monde anglo saxon le charity quelque
chose d'important
oui alors vous dire deux mots c'est ça
s'appelle la woman cardiovasculaires
healthcare foundation en france agir
pour le coeur des femmes qui est une
fondation une fondation à vocation
internationale avec un seul objectif qui
est de combat que la première cause de
mortalité des femmes en france oui et
dans le monde que sont les pathologies
cardiovasculaires alors on retrouvera ça
on retrouve tout ça sur internet avec
précision mais ce qui est intéressant
dans le cadre de notre discussion
d'avant c'est que c'est une tradition
finalement anglo saxon sa de finance et
de la recherche par par les dons et par
la générosité
alors ce n'est pas que de la recherche
et du très concret mais c'est le fameux
give back
oui c'est le fameux comment est-ce que
je participe à l'intelligence collective
comment est ce que je fais en sorte de
pouvoir m'intéresser aux autres et
combattre et m'investir sur un sujet qui
est un sujet important on retrouve ça
dans la ligue de lutte contre le cancer
en france et dans un sapin et puis et
puis vous savez on a on a beaucoup parlé
de très grands bienfaiteurs on n'a pas
être bill gates et autres etc
il n'y a pas de raison pour lequel en
europe on ne soit pas capable de
construire une grande fondation qui plus
est pour combattre la première cause de
mortalité des femmes hébergées dans le
monde et je voudrais en profiter pour
pour dire qu'on associe des expertises
et que j'ai à mes côtés la co fondatrice
qui est le professeur carmine éveillé
qui est une des plus grandes qu'à deux
longueurs au niveau européen qui est une
femme formidable
et là ce serait l'europe au sens large
trait l'allemand tiendrions merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir apporté
votre votre témoignage votre expérience
surtout de votre connaissance des
relations avec
grande bretagne cette émission est
terminée on la retrouve bien sûr en
replay sur la chaîne on la retrouve sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis sur le site
internet arte france point tv à très
bientôt
[Musique]